Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Hello everybody. Now Theo, our producer, has asked me to point out to you that this episode is very, very gory. So if you're listening in the car with small children, consider yourselves warned. Enjoy. It was the popular theme for jests, it was the best cure for headache. It infallibly prevented the hair from turning grey. It imparted a peculiar delicacy to the complexion. It was the national razor which shaved close. Who kissed La guillotine looked through the little window and sneezed into
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好。我们的制片人西奥让我提醒大家，本集内容非常、非常血腥。因此，如果您正和幼小的儿童在车里收听，请做好心理准备。祝收听愉快。这是人们热议的笑话，也是治疗头痛的良方。它能绝对防止头发变白。它赋予了脸色一种奇特的娇嫩感。它是削得精光的国民剃刀。谁吻了吉头机，透过那扇小窗户，在
the sack. It was the sign of the regeneration of the human race. It superseded the cross. Models of it were worn on breasts from which the cross was discarded and it was bowed down to and believed in where the cross was denied. It sheared off heads so many that it and the ground it most polluted were a rotten red. It was taken to pieces like a toy puzzle for a young devil and was put together again when the occasion wanted it. It hushed the eloquent, struck down the powerful, abolished the beautiful and good. Twenty friends of high public mark, 21 living and one dead. It had lopped the heads off in one morning in as many minutes. The name of the strongman of old scripture had descended to the chief functionary who
麻袋里打了个喷嚏。它是人类社会重生的标志。它取代了十字架。人们佩戴着它的模型在胸前，而十字架却被抛弃了；在十字架被否认的地方，人们向它顶礼膜拜并对它深信不疑。它斩下了无数的头颅，以至于它和它污染最严重的土地都变成了一片腐烂的血红色。它像一件给小恶魔玩的拼图玩具一样被拆开，又在需要的时候重新组装起来。它让能言善辩者噤声，将权势滔天者击倒，消灭了美好与善良。二十位声名显赫的人物，二十一位活着的和一位死去的。它在一个早晨的短短几分钟内，就割下了这些人的头颅。古代圣经中大力士的名字传承给了
worked it. But so armed he was stronger than his namesake and blinder and tore away the gates of God's own temple every day. So that was Charles Dickens in A Tale of Two Cities and he is writing of course about the guillotine. And Tom when people think about the French Revolution in the English speaking world in particular, the guillotine is at the absolute centre of our mental picture isn't it. There's the guillotine, the blade stained with blood, there's the basket with the heads of the aristocrats. There are kind of cackling, orc-faced old women with knitting needles, knitting at their foot and the sort of the grim, pale sort of mermodons of the revolution who are ordering more carts to
操作它的首席刽子手。但拥有这样的武器，他比他的同名者更加强大，也更加盲目，每天都在撕裂上帝自己圣殿的大门。以上是查尔斯·狄更斯在《双城记》中的文字，他写的当然是断头台。汤姆，当英语世界的人们想起法国大革命时，断头台绝对处于我们脑海中画面的正中心，对吧？有断头台，沾满鲜血的刀片，有装满贵族头颅的篮子。还有那种咯咯笑着的、兽面人身的老妇人，拿着织针，在他们的脚边织着毛衣，以及革命中那些冷酷、脸色苍白的小喽啰，他们正命令更多的马车
rattle through the streets. Tumbrils. revolution who are ordering more carts to rattle through the streets with guests of Madame Guillotine. So we thought now we'd talk about the guillotine as the supreme symbol of the revolution. Because of course it's at this point in the story that the guillotine starts to feature. So I think you're absolutely right that for us in the English speaking world, the guillotine is perhaps the supreme symbol of the revolution and particularly of the terror. And often in the English speaking world, the two are conflated. So the guillotine, I think, for Dickens and for Carlisle before
在街上得隆隆驶过。运囚车。革命中那些冷酷、脸色苍白的小喽啰，正命令更多的马车载着吉约廷夫人的客人们在街上得隆隆驶过。所以我们现在想谈谈作为革命最高象征的断头台。因为当然，正是在故事的这个节点，断头台开始登场。所以我觉得你说得完全没错，对于我们英语世界的人来说，断头台也许是革命的最高象征，尤其是恐怖统治的象征。而且在英语世界中，这两者往往被混为一谈。因此，我认为断头台，对狄更斯、对之前的卡莱尔
him and for English people who lived through the revolutionary period, it was an object of dread because it facilitated slaughter on an almost industrial scale. Enormous quantities of people are being killed in kind of mass execution sessions. But also because the guillotine ends up in the very centre of Paris. And so it enshrines a spectacle of death physically at the heart of the capital of the country that is going through the revolution. And you see it, it's kind of menace endures in Master and Commander, where Russell Crowe, when he's rallying his men to face the French, he has the line, do you want to see a guillotine
以及对经历过革命时期的英国人来说，它是一个令人恐惧的对象，因为它促成了近乎工业化规模的大屠杀。大量的人在某种集体处决中被杀害。而且也是因为断头台最终出现在了巴黎的市中心。因此，它将死亡的奇观实体化地镌刻在经历革命的那个国家首都的心脏地带。你看，它的那种威胁感在电影《怒海争锋》中得以延续，拉塞尔·克劳在动员他的手下对抗法国人时，有这样一句台词：你们想在皮卡迪利大街看到断头台吗？
in Piccadilly? Do you want your children to sing their master eyes? No, terrible prospects, obviously. So the shadow of the guillotine, I think, hangs heavy over the English imagination. But I think in France, obviously it has slightly different connotations. In France, the guillotine continues to be used long after the revolution because it is seen as being the most humane and progressive method of execution. And amazingly, the last public guillotining takes place as late as June 1939. That's bonkers.
你们想让孩子们歌唱主人的眼睛吗？不，这显然是可怕的前景。因此，我认为断头台的阴影沉重地笼罩着英国人的想象力。但我认为在法国，它显然有着稍微不同的内涵。在法国，断头台在革命后很久仍然被继续使用，因为它被视为最人道、最进步的处决方式。令人难以置信的是，最后一次公开执行断头台死刑竟然一直持续到1939年6月。这太疯狂了。
And a serial killer is executed outside the prison he's been kept in and the place where he's executed is Versailles. It's amazing irony. Do we know how many people went to watch it? I mean, that's mad, isn't it? A fair few, I think. Unbelievable. And actually, Dominic, the last person in France to be guillotined, he's executed in September 1977, which is five months after the release of Star Wars. That's crazy. The fact that you could, I mean, at least it wasn't public because otherwise you could have gone to see both in a single year. I mean, that's crazy. And I think, you know, it's not just the French who share this assumption that the guillotine
一个连环杀手在他被关押的监狱外被处决，而他被处决的地方就是凡尔赛。这真是惊人的讽刺。我们知道有多少人去看吗？我的意思是，这太疯狂了，不是吗？我想挺多的。难以置信。事实上，多米尼克，法国最后一个被送上断头台的人是在1977年9月被处决的，这距离《星球大战》上映仅仅五个月。太疯狂了。你可以——我的意思是，至少这不是公开的，否则你完全可以在同一年去看了这两样东西。我的意思是，这太疯狂了。而且我认为，你知道，不仅是法国人有这种假设，即断头台
is progressive and humane. And you can see this because it gets adopted in lots of countries that are inspired by the French revolution. So in Belgium, in Switzerland, in Sweden, in Greece, actually in Germany, I mean, we did the white rose, didn't we? The activists who opposed the Nazis and who ended up being guillotined. But we also talked about how von Papen, the afeet bouffant haired aristocrat who precedes Hitler. And he viewed the guillotine as too humane, too Afite. And he wanted it abolished and replaced with the axe, which he saw as much more traditionally Germanic. I think both sides of that argument are pretty debranged. Yeah. But I think the English and the French attitude to the guillotine is what makes it
是进步且人道的。你可以看到这一点，因为它在许多受法国大革命启发的国家都被采用了。比如在比利时、瑞士、瑞典、希腊，实际上还有德国——我的意思是，我们讲过“白玫瑰”的故事，对吧？那些反对纳粹最终被送上断头台的活动人士。但我们也谈到过巴本，那个在希特勒之前、头发蓬松的自负贵族。他认为断头台太人道了，太软弱了。他希望废除断头台，用斧头取而代之，他认为斧头更具有传统的日耳曼风格。我认为争论的双方都挺精神错乱的。是的。但我认为英国人和法国人对断头台的态度，正是它成为
the perfect symbol of the revolution, because it's seen as being simultaneously a symbol of horror, a symbol of humane enlightenment, an emblem of terror, an emblem of compassion almost. It's spattered in blood, but it is a clean method of execution. And those paradoxes are beautifully exemplify broader paradoxes about the revolution. And so because of that, because the guillotine has this totemic status, listeners may be wondering, we haven't mentioned it really until now. We kind of alluded to it at the end of the last episode. And the reason for that is that it isn't introduced until 1792. But having said that, it's not as though the revolution hasn't already displayed a taste for public displays of punishment and of retribution. So Dominic, in the episode you did on the Bastille,
革命完美象征的原因，因为它被视为恐怖的象征、人道启蒙的象征、恐怖统治的标志、几乎是同情心的标志的结合体。它溅满了鲜血，但它却是一种干净的处决方式。这些悖论完美地体现了关于革命更广泛的悖论。正因如此，因为断头台具有这种图腾般的地位，听众们可能会想，我们直到现在才真正提到它。我们在上一集的结尾曾隐晦地提到过它。原因在于它直到1792年才被引入。话虽如此，这并不是说在此之前革命没有表现出对公开惩罚和报复展示的偏好。所以，多米尼克，你在关于巴士底狱的那一集里，
you drew attention to the fact that alongside the role the Bastille plays as a narrative of despotism being overthrown, of the banner of liberty being planted on the stones of toppled despotism. There are also salutary displays of punishment. Yeah. And on that day, so notoriously, there's Fuon, isn't there? The guy who said, let them eat straw and his son-in-law and they're both decapitated and their heads are put on pikes and their mouths are stuffed with straw and they're paraded
你提到了这样一个事实：除了巴士底狱作为专制被推翻、自由旗帜插在被推翻的专制废墟上的叙事角色之外，还有一些具有警示意义的惩罚展示。是的。而在那一天，最臭名昭著的就是弗隆，对吧？那个说过“让他们吃草吧”的人以及他的女婿，他们两个都被斩首了，他们的头颅被插在长矛上，嘴里塞满了草，然后在街上游行
round and they kind of bring the two heads together and they shout out kiss papa to the head of the son-in-law. And then the one that we did last time, the upskirters at the Chande-de-Mars, when they get caught, they get beheaded and their heads get paraded round. And in all these cases, the way that they are killed is by being hung from a lamppost, a lantern. And so the great revolutionary cry of vengeance and punishment is always a la lantern. And Camille Desmoulins, who we've talked about a lot, his journalism in September 1789, so just a few months after the storming of the Bastille, he kind of ventriloquizes a lantern, giving a talk in this remarkable piece of journalism called The Lantern Speaks
他们把两个头颅凑在一起，对着女婿的头大喊“亲亲爸爸”。然后是我们上次讲的那次，在战神广场偷窥裙底的人，当他们被抓住时，他们被斩首，头颅被到处游行。在所有这些情况下，他们被杀死的方式都是被吊在路灯柱上，也就是路灯上。因此，复仇和惩罚的伟大革命口号一直是“把他们挂在路灯上”（à la lanterne）。我们经常谈论的卡米尔·德穆兰，他在1789年9月的政治新闻报道中——也就是攻占巴士底狱几个月后——他借路灯之口，在一篇名为《路灯对巴黎人说话》的出色新闻报道中发表了一番演讲。
to the Parisians. And he imagines the lantern saying, thank you for making me so famous, for making me so admired, then complains, there are so many criminals, there are so many villains who've escaped me, I want more. And I guess it casts a slightly sinister perspective on Desmoulins journalism. You also mentioned this other article he wrote, the Declaration of the Rights of the Accuser in the last episode we did, the one we did on Tuesday. So I mean, his journalism is quite intimidating, isn't it? Well, also Tom, that, Lansing speaks to the Parisians, what's that? September 1789. So so early on in the story of the revolution. So that thirst for vengeance and that blood
他想象路灯在说：感谢你们让我如此出名，让我如此受人仰慕，然后抱怨道：有那么多的罪犯，有那么多的恶棍逃脱了我的惩罚，我想要更多。我想这给德穆兰的新闻报道投上了一层略显阴险的阴暗视角。你在上一集——我们在周二录制的那一集里，也提到了他写的另一篇文章《控告人权利宣言》。所以我的意思是，他的新闻报道相当具有威慑力，对吧？嗯，还有汤姆，那个《路灯对巴黎人说话》，那是什时候？1789年9月。所以在革命故事的早期。所以那种对复仇的渴望和嗜血
thirstiness isn't a later, you know, it's not that Dickens and Carlisle have tainted the revolution by pretending that it was always there. It was always there. Well, it's an instinct, isn't it? Demulai is articulating a kind of particularly radical and aggressive take on the revolution. And actually most of the enthusiasts for the revolution, most of the delegates to the National Assembly are twitchy about the idea of revolutionary justice. So in the two years that follow the fall of the Bastille, you know, there are regular lynchings. So between May 1790 and
并非后来才有的，你知道，并不是狄更斯和卡莱尔通过假装它一直存在而玷污了革命。它一直都在。嗯，这是一种本能，对吧？德穆兰表达了一种对革命特别激进而又具有攻击性的立场。事实上，大多数革命的狂热分子、国民议会的绝大多数代表，对革命审判的想法都感到神经紧绷。因此，在巴士底狱陷落之后的两年里，你知道，经常发生私刑。因此，在1790年5月到
February 1792, 13 lynchings are known to have taken place in Parisian neighborhoods. And to delegates at the national assembly, to people who see themselves as the embodiment of the revolution, this is terrifying. I mean, this is an expression of the incipient anarchy that lots and lots of them are worried about. But there is this kind of sense on the streets among the radical journalists like Desmoulins and Marat that these lynchings aren't just legitimate but that they are a kind of patriotic expression of revolutionary values. And this is very potently expressed in the first great anthem of the French revolution, Saira. So it's all going to be fine. And the initial lyrics of that are actually quite dull.
1792年2月之间，已知在巴黎街区发生了13起私刑。对于国民议会的代表们来说，对于那些将自己视为革命化身的人来说，这太可怕了。我的意思是，这是他们许多人一直担心的隐蔽无政府状态的一种表现。但在街头的激进记者中，比如德穆兰和马拉，有一种感觉，即这些私刑不仅是合法的，而且它们是革命价值观的一种爱国主义表现。这一点在法国大革命的第一首伟大赞歌《 Ça Ira 》中得到了非常有力的表达：一切都会好起来的。而这首歌最初的歌词其实相当枯燥。
It's full of kind of stuff like when Boileau spoke about the clergy. It sounds great. Boileau spoke about the clergy. It's not great stuff. They mentioned the prudent Lafayette, the careful Lafayette. So lots of enthusiasm for him as well. But the lyrics get more and more radical and it ends up the most vengeful version kind of explicitly promises, les aristocrates à la lanterne, the aristocrats will be hanged from the lamp post. And this becomes so totemic that in the opening ceremony of the Olympics in Paris this summer, this is what Marie Antoinette, the beheaded Marie Antoinette is singing. And the reason that it becomes totemic is that it is summoning up the idea of executions,
充满了诸如布瓦洛谈论神职人员之类的内容。听起来很棒。布瓦洛谈论神职人员。这可不是什么好东西。他们提到了谨慎的拉斐特，细心的拉斐特。所以大家对他也充满了热情。但歌词变得越来越激进，最终最复仇主义的版本明确承诺：把贵族挂在路灯上（les aristocrates à la lanterne），贵族将被吊在路灯柱上。这变得如此具有图腾意义，以至于在今年夏天巴黎奥运会的开幕式上，这就是被斩首的玛丽·安托瓦内特所演唱的内容。它之所以成为图腾，是因为它唤起了处决的概念，
mass executions as a kind of purging of France, as a public display of violence that is assumed to be not just necessary on a kind of purely criminal level, but a catharsis, a freeing of France from the taint and evil of what has gone before. And again that's not just Anglo-Saxon projection because if you look at the rhetoric of your Marat, Robespierre, Saint-Juice later on in the revolution, they absolutely say that a republic of virtue can only be born through blood. But here's the thing, Dominic, this idea that executions should instill a powerful and dramatic moral lesson, which the French Revolution absolutely buys into, is not original to the French Revolution.
大规模处决被视为一种对法国的净化，作为一种暴力的人前展示，人们认为这不仅在纯粹的犯罪层面上是必要的，而且是一种宣泄，一种将法国从过去的污点和邪恶中解放出来的过程。同样，这不仅仅是盎格ルー-撒克逊人的投射，因为如果你看看马拉、罗伯斯庇尔、圣茹斯特在革命后期发表的言论，他们绝对说过，美德共和国只能通过鲜血才能诞生。但问题是，多米尼克，这种认为处决应该灌输强大而戏剧性的道德教训的想法——法国大革命绝对接受了这一点——并非法国大革命所独创。
It is an assumption that derives from the Ancien Régime. So it comes naturally to people in France, because they have been raised to take it for granted. And so often in the series, obviously, we recognise how complete the rupture is that the Revolution embodies, but also traced the way in which there are continuities. And in the context of executions, in the process by which the guillotine comes to be invented and enshrined at the heart of the revolution, there is one really totemic figure who exemplifies this. And it's a man who was mentioned by Dickens, the strong man of old scripture, which of course is Samson. And the name of probably the most famous executioner in French history and maybe all history, he is Saint-Saëns, Charles-Henri Saint-Saëns. And he claimed over the course of his life to have executed something like 3000 people. Many of these are some of the most famous names in the history
这是一种源自旧制度的假设。所以这对于法国人来说是很自然的，因为他们从小就被教育将其视为理所当然。在这整个系列中，我们当然认识到革命所体现的断裂是多么彻底，但也追溯了延续性存在的种种方式。而在处决的语境中，在断头台被发明并被奉为革命核心的过程中，有一个非常具有图腾色彩的人物完美地体现了这一点。这个人就是狄更斯提到的那个古代圣经中的大力士，当然就是桑松。法国历史上、或许也是所有历史中最著名的刽子手的名字，他就是圣桑，查尔斯-亨利·圣桑。他声称在自己的一生中处决了大约3000人。其中许多人是法国革命史上最著名的名字。
of the French revolution. But before the revolution, he had served as the royal executioner of France. And he is one of an entire dynasty of executioners. It's a family business. Well, as we'll see, it's something more than a business. But his great grandfather, who was also called Charles Saint-Saens, had been appointed the Parisian executioner back in 1688. And before the Saint-Saens become the executioning dynasty, there had been a previous dynasty of executioners called the Guillaume who'd been in office since 1594. So as you say, a family business, but also something much more because under
但在革命之前，他曾担任法国的皇家刽子手。他是整个刽子手王朝的一员。这是一个家族企业。嗯，正如我们所见，这不仅仅是一桩生意。但他的曾祖父，也叫查尔斯·圣桑，早在1688年就被任命为巴黎的刽子手了。在圣桑家族成为刽子手王朝之前，曾有过一个名为纪尧姆的早期刽子手王朝，他们自1594年以来一直在职。所以正如你所说，这是一个家族企业，但也远不止于此，因为在
the monarchy, the executioner, he's not a kind of an agent of rational justice. He's not a bureaucrat. He's not a functionary employed by the state. He's something much weirder, much more menacing than that. And there is a brilliant book on this by Paul Friedland called Seeing Justice Done, the Age of Spectacular Capital Punishment in France. And when I was doing the research for this, I wanted something that would take me deeper than most of the books on the French Revolution that I've got do. And I went to the London library, they got stacks of books and I went through all the things, you know, the various shelves. And this was the book I found and it's superb.
君主制统治下，刽子手并不是理性正义的代理人。他不是官僚，也不是受雇于国家的职能人员。他是一种更诡异、更具威胁的存在。保罗·弗里德兰（Paul Friedland）为此写了一本精彩绝伦的书，书名叫《伸张正义：法国壮观死刑的时代》（Seeing Justice Done: The Age of Spectacular Capital Punishment in France）。当我在做这方面的研究时，我想要一本比我手头大多数关于法国大革命的书挖掘得更深的书。我去了伦敦图书馆，那里有成堆的书籍，我翻阅了所有东西，你知道的，各种书架。这就是我找到的那本书，它棒极了。
It tells you, you know, all the deep history of it, which we'll be going into in this episode. So essentially what you're going to hear in this episode, it comes from Friedland's book. And in fact, Dominic, I mentioned to you that the last public execution in France took place in outside Versailles in 1939. And Friedland has actually done a video on that as well, a lecture. So if guillotining is your thing, Paul Friedland is your man. Anyway, he explains exactly what it is that's weird and menacing about the figure of the executioner by comparing them to other groups of people. So he says that they're like Jews in pre-revolutionary France in that they're outcasts and Jews in
它告诉你，你知道的，所有深厚的历史，我们将在本集节目中深入探讨。所以基本上你在这集节目中听到的一切，都源自弗里德兰的书。事实上，多米尼克，我曾向你提到，法国最后一次公开处决于1939年在凡尔赛郊外举行。弗里德兰实际上也为此做过一个视频，一场讲座。所以如果使用断头台是你的爱好，保罗·弗里德兰就是你的不二人选。无论如何，他通过将刽子手与其他人群进行比较，准确地解释了刽子手形象的诡异和威胁之处。因此他说，他们就像前革命时期法国的犹太人，因为他们是被驱逐者，而犹太人在
Christian societies for a long, long time have performed the role of usury, which obviously makes them hated and feared. And the executioner similarly is seen to be doing something that's very important, that's very essential to the functioning of the state, and yet puts him beyond the pale, marks him as a kind of figure of sin and menace. And again, like Jews, but also like prostitutes and like lepers, they are restricted to certain quarters of town. There's a sense that their very presence kind of spreads a form of moral pestilence. They can't be allowed to come into contact with decent citizens. So as late as 1781, a riot breaks out when an executioner goes to the local
基督教社会中，长期以来一直扮演着高利贷的角色，这显然使他们备受憎恨和恐惧。同样，刽子手也被认为在做一件对国家运作非常重要、非常必不可少的事情，然而这却将他置于社会规范之外，将他标记为一个充满罪恶和威胁的存在。同样，就像犹太人，但也像妓女麻风病人一样，他们被限制在城镇的某些特定区域。人们觉得他们的存在本身就在传播某种道德瘟疫。他们绝不能与正派公民接触。直到1781年，当一名刽子手去当地
theatre to see a play and the entire audience kind of erupts and hurls him out. So it's a bit like being an MP in Britain today. Yeah, a bit like being an MP in Britain today. A bit. A bit. A necessary but unpleasant part of the national life. But what MPs don't have to do, which the executioner did, is wear distinctive clothing. So executioners would have official costumes and it would be prescribed by the different towns.
剧院看戏时，骚乱爆发了，全场观众群情激愤，将他赶了出去。所以这有点像今天英国的国会议员。对，有点像今天英国的国会议员。有一点。有一点。这是国家生活中必不可少但又令人不快的组成部分。但国会议员不必做、而刽子手必须做的一件事，就是穿具有辨识度的服装。因此，刽子手会有官方的制服，这是由不同的城镇规定的。
So in Paris, the royal executioner always has to wear a blood red coat. Like a hunting coat. Yes. Yeah, but of course, you know, stained with the mark of his trade. Yeah. Wow. So very menacing, but Friedland also points out that they are actually possessed of an almost royal charisma. So this is why they have hereditary dynasties. You know, this is something that kings do. They are reputed to cure diseases with their touch, which again is something that Kings
所以在巴黎，皇家刽子手总是必须穿一件血红色的外套。就像狩猎夹克一样。是的。是的，但当然，你知道的，上面沾满了他的职业印记。是的。哇。所以非常具有威胁性，但弗里德兰也指出，他们实际上拥有几乎是王室般的个人魅力。这就是为什么他们有世袭王朝的原因。你知道，这是国王们才会做的事。传说他们通过触摸就能治愈疾病，这同样是国王们
traditionally do, kind of scrofula, whatever. And they have these rights to walk through marketplaces and take whatever they want for their daily use. What? Like sort of supermarket sweep kind of thing? Yes, exactly. That's, that's crazy. But what makes it even more like a game show is that they're not actually allowed to pick anything up with their fingers or hands because their touch
传统上会做的事，比如治疗淋巴结核什么的。他们享有穿行于集市的权利，可以拿走他们日常所需的任何东西。什么？就像某种超市大扫货一样的东西？对，没错。这、这太疯狂了。但让它更像是一个游戏节目的是，他们实际上不允许用手指或手去捡任何东西，因为他们的触摸
is tainted. They have in Paris, they have a tin plated spoon. So what if you want to buy like clothing? How does your spoon help you then? No, it doesn't. It's if you're getting coffee or sugar or whatever. Right. It's helping yourself with this. I think it's like a big spoon. Oh, it is a massive spoon. Yeah, massive. Yes. It's a yourself with this. I think it's like a big spoon. Oh, it is a massive spoon. Yeah, massive spoon. Yes, it's a huge tin-plated spoon. The spoon with which Alan Partridge would go to the market. Like a huge spoon. Well, trying to raise Alan Partridge from your mind, I'll give you a brilliant description
是被污染的。他们在巴黎有一个镀锡的勺子。那么如果你想买衣服怎么办？那你的勺子有什么用？不，没用。那是如果你在买咖啡或糖之类的时候。没错。这是用来帮你自己弄这个的。我觉得这就像一个大勺子。哦，是个巨大的勺子。对，巨大的勺子。是的，这是一个巨大的镀锡勺子。阿兰·帕特里奇去集市时会带的那种勺子。就像一个巨大的勺子。好吧，试着把阿兰·帕特里奇从你的脑海中赶出去，我给你念一段来自弗里德兰书中的精彩描述。
from Friedland's book. It is not difficult, Friedland writes, to imagine the shudder that went through the crowd at the approach of this figure dressed in his required ceremonial robes, bearing perhaps the insignia of the gallows, accompanied by his wife and by his aides, often drawn from the ranks of younger siblings or cousins. And all these people, individuals whom one usually caught sight of only when they were rooting around in sewers, skinning dead animals, harassing lepers and prostitutes, and of course, rending the flesh of live human beings on the scaffold would fan out across the marketplace and begin to demand their allotted egg, their measure of butter and their herring, et cetera, et cetera. Spoon or no spoon, they made everyone
弗里德兰写道，不难想象，当这个穿着规定礼仪长袍、可能带着绞刑架标志、由妻子和助手们（这些助手通常是从年幼的兄弟或表亲中挑选出来的）陪同的身影走近时，人群中会激起怎样的战栗。所有这些人——你通常只有在他们翻找下水道、剥死动物皮、骚扰麻风病人和妓女、当然还有在断头台上撕裂活人血肉时才能瞥见的一一个个体——会散落到集市的各处，开始索要他们应得的鸡蛋、黄油、鲱鱼等等，等等。不管有没有勺子，他们都让每个人
cringe. Mason- Theo would make it. I mean, Theo could have done that stuff. It's like being a producer at GoHang. I have to say, it's a great passage and Friedland's book is, I mean, it's a wonderful work of scholarship. It's also brilliantly well written as well. So all very weird, but I think it adds to the sense of horror that a condemned person feels to be handed over to such a man. Because I think there's a sense that his very touch is a form of the punishment. And to go from being someone who has not been convicted of a crime to being convicted of a crime is symbolized by the fact that this guy with his spoon and his
感到不寒而栗。梅森-西奥也能写出这样的东西。我的意思是西奥完全可以做那种事。这就像在“GoHang”当制片人一样。我必须说，这是一段精彩的段落，弗里德兰的书——我的意思是，这是一部绝妙的学术著作。它的文笔也极其优美。所以这一切都非常诡异，但我认为这加剧了被判刑者落入这样一个人手中时感到的恐惧。因为我觉得人们有一种感觉，他的触摸本身就是一种惩罚。而从一个未被定罪的人转变为一个被定罪的人，其标志就是这个拿着勺子、穿着
red coat and everything lurches forward and physically takes possession of you, physically takes command of you. And it's a marker of the fact that you've kind of passed beyond the limits of the decent citizen into a dimension of punishment. And the execution is responsive. He's not just doing the actual capital punishment. So he would also be doing brandings or locking people up in the pillory or shackling them to be taken to the galleys. So we talked about Joan de la Motte, the fraudster in the case of the affair of the diamond necklace and how she's branded and shaved and everything. That is the role of the executioner. He's doing that. If you think about that, the process by which Joan de la Motte, for instance, is given the kind of coarse robe and sentenced to what had been a hospital for penitence, there is a sense in which all of this display, all
红色外套以及一切的家伙大步向前，实质上占有了你，实质上控制了你。这标志着你已经跨越了正派公民的界限，进入了惩罚的维度。而且刽子手是负责响应的。他不仅负责实际的死刑执行。他还要负责打烙印、把人关在枷锁里，或者戴上镣铐送去划船。所以我们谈到了让娜·德·拉莫特，那个在钻石项链案中的骗子，以及她是如何被烙印、剃光头等等的。这就是刽子手的角色。他在做这些事。如果你想想那个过程，比如让娜·德·拉莫特被套上粗布长袍，并被判送到曾作为忏悔者医院的地方，从某种意义上说，所有这些展示、所有
of this kind of weirdness is about repentance as well as punishment. It's clearly steeped in kind of very deeply Catholic notions of penance and absolution. And when you read about accounts of executions, it's as though the route to the scaffold is almost conjuring up echoes of a passion play. There's the sense in which the journey from the prison to the scaffold is about turning a criminal back into a Christian ready to be received by his or her creator. So there's a French scholar, Michel Bay, who's brilliant on this. So he writes, the criminal who has violated the prohibition of murder has by his act entered into the world of the sacred. He has endowed himself with an energy that renders his presence harmful and contagious. He introduces disorder
这种诡异之处，既关乎忏悔，也关乎惩罚。它显然深深浸透了极其浓厚的、天主教式的苦修和赦免观念。当你读到关于处决的记录时，仿佛通往断头台的道路几乎唤起了受难剧的回忆。人们有一种感觉，从监狱到断头台的旅程，是将一个罪犯重新变成一个准备好被其造物主接纳的基督徒的过程。因此，有一位法国学者米歇尔·拜（Michel Foucault，此处发音接近），他在研究这个方面非常出色。所以他写道：侵犯了谋杀禁忌的罪犯，通过他的行为进入了神圣的世界。他赋予了自己一种能量，使他的存在变得有害且具有传染性。他在社会中以及在社会与神圣的关系中引入了混乱。
into society and in the relations between society with the divine. The only reconciliation possible between the murderer and the society rests therefore in the sacrifice which frees him from his stain. So Tom, does that mean, well, we started with Dickens when you think of a kind of Dickensian London or 18th century London execution, there are people kind of hooting with laughter, eating pies. It's a tremendous carnival. Does that suggest that in France there is a perhaps more somber atmosphere and that it feels more like a religious ceremony than they are to the fair?
因此，谋杀者与社会之间唯一可能的和解，在于将他从污点中解放出来的牺牲。所以，汤姆，这是否意味着——好吧，我们从狄更斯开始，当你想到狄更斯笔下的伦敦或18世纪的伦敦处决时，人们会发出嘘声、吃着馅饼，这是一场巨大的狂欢。这是否表明在法国，气氛可能更 加阴郁，而且它感觉更像是一个宗教仪式，而不是集市？
As we will see, public executions are hugely popular. As in England, they have the quality of a grand sports occasion. People look forward to them hugely. But I think there is a, dare I say, sacral quality to them that in Protestant England you don't get. You just don't have the Catholic echoes of penance and absolution that you get in an execution in France. And this is why, I mean, we talked before about Jean Callin, who was the Protestant who gets falsely accused of killing his son, gets broken on the wheel. His case gets taken up by Voltaire who campaigns against it. And he's a crazy, the fam is the monstrousness of the religious system that required him to be broken like that. But Voltaire's campaign
正如我们将看到的，公开处决极其受欢迎。和英格兰一样，它们具有盛大体育盛事的性质。人们非常期待它们。但我认为它们有一种，恕我直言，神圣的品质，你在新教英格兰是找不到的。你根本没有在法国处决中那种天主教式的苦修和赦免的回应。这就是为什么——我的意思是，我们之前谈到过让·卡拉（Jean Calas），那个被诬告杀害儿子、被施以车裂的新教徒。他的案子被伏尔泰接手，伏尔泰为此展开了运动。这是一个疯狂的事件，这个宗教体制的野蛮性要求将他那样车裂。但伏尔泰的运动
works because there are Catholic instincts as well that would say that torturing to death an innocent person on an instrument of torture is also against Christian traditions for very obvious reasons. So the Cala case is kind of pointing to the way in which even before the revolution, people are starting to have reservations about what is happening, that there is something, well, you know, this is an age when everyone basically is still very devoutly Christian. There is something unchristian about it. And this is exemplified by the most notorious of all public executions that takes place in the Ancien Régime. And this happens in 1757 in the reign of Louis XV, so the grandfather of Louis XVI.
之所以起作用，是因为也有天主教的天性会说，在酷刑工具上将一个无辜的人折磨至死，出于非常明显的原因，也是违背基督教传统的。所以卡拉案指出了这样一种趋势：甚至在革命之前，人们就开始对正在发生的事情产生保留意见，即这里面有些东西——好吧，你知道，这是一个每个人基本上仍然非常虔诚信仰基督教的时代。这里面有些东西是不符合基督教精神的。而旧制度中所有公开处决里最臭名昭著的一起，就是最好的例证。这发生在1757年路易十五统治时期，也就是路易十六的祖父在位期间。
And it is a punishment that is inflicted on a domestic servant called Robert François d'Amin, who had attempted to kill Louis XV, to stab him with a dagger, as Louis XV was entering Versailles in a carriage. And Damien gets seized and imprisoned, and the executioners prepare for him a fate that is designed to be the most terrifying, the most salutary spectacle that the French justice system can possibly devise. And everybody knows about this. And if you think of it as being like a great sports occasion, you know, this is the world cup final where your team has qualified. Yeah. You know, this is the biggest match that you've ever seen. So you
这是对一名叫罗贝尔-弗朗索瓦·达米安的仆人的惩罚，他曾试图杀死路易十五，在路易十五乘马车进入凡尔赛时用匕首刺杀他。达米安被捕并入狱，刽子手为他准备了一种命运，旨在成为法国司法系统所能设计出的最可怕、最具有警示意义的奇观。每个人都知道这一点。如果你把它想象成一场盛大的体育赛事，你知道，这就是你的球队打进决赛的世界杯决赛。是的。你知道，这是你见过最大的一场比赛。所以你
get two months before the actual execution, you get a newspaper called the Gazette d'Amsterdam writing, never has a spectacle had as many spectators as the punishment of Damien will have. People are whipping themselves up into a frenzy of excitement about it. And of course it's a massive occasion for the young lad, Charles Henri Sanson, who's only 18, kind of pretty much making his debut as a superstar executioner. So he doesn't want to mess up and he will be assisting his uncle, Nicolas Sanson on the big day. So a huge occasion for him, huge occasion for Damien. Yeah.
在实际处决前两个月，就会看到一份名为《阿姆斯特丹公报》（Gazette d'Amsterdam）的报纸写道：从来没有一个奇观能像惩罚达米安那样拥有如此多的观众。人们为之兴奋狂热。当然，对于年轻的小伙子查尔斯-亨利·桑松来说，这是一个巨大的时刻，他年仅18岁，基本上可以说是作为超级巨星刽子手的首秀。所以他不想搞砸，他将在大日子里协助他的叔叔尼古拉·桑松。所以对他来说是个巨大的时刻，对达米安来说也是个巨大的时刻。是的。
How's it going to go down? Is it going to measure up to expectations? So the day of the execution arrives, the crowds are indeed massive. The authorities have to set up barriers to keep them back. The wealthy have kind of hired rooms so that they can look out over it. It's noted that lots of the people there are women. So we have a diarist, Monsieur Babier, and he wrote in his diary, people noticed that there were many women and even some of distinction and they never left the windows and that they were better able to stand the horror of the
这将会怎么发展？它能达到预期吗？处决的日子到了，人群果然人山人海。当局不得不设置路障来阻挡他们。富人们租下了房间，以便从高处眺望。人们注意到，现场有很多人是女性。所以我们有一位日记作者巴比耶先生（Monsieur Barbier），他在日记中写道：人们注意到有许多女性，甚至还有一些是有身份地位的女性，她们从未离开过窗户，而且她们比男性更能承受这种恐怖的
punishment than the men. Something that did not do them honor. Women are made of stronger stuff though, aren't they Tom? That's the lesson of history. Well, the horror is indeed immense. So on the morning of his execution, which is the 28th of March, 1757, so he's had kind of a month and a half to ponder what's going to happen to him. The jailers come and he's alleged to have said, la journée s'arrude. This is going to be a terrible day. That's such a kind of sportsman thing to say, like, you know, it's going to be a tough game, Tom, but I'll, uh, I'll take each moment as it comes.
惩罚。这并没有为她们增光。然而女性的内心是由更坚强的材料构成的，不是吗，汤姆？这就是历史的教训。好吧，这种恐怖确实是巨大的。因此，在他处决的那天早晨，也就是1757年3月28日——所以他有一个半月的时间来思考将会发生什么。狱警们来了，据说他说过这样一句话：la journée s'arrude（今天将会是艰难的一天）。这真是一句非常体育迷风格的话，就像，你知道的，这将是一场艰难的比赛，汤姆，但我会，呃，我会把握好每一个时刻。
Yeah. Dig deep. Yeah. So it is indeed a terrible day for Balad Damian. So he gets put into a tumbrel. Uh, he gets given a torch of burning wax to carry and he's taken to the square where executions conventionally happen, which is the Place de Grève by the Hotel de Ville. The hand with which he had plunged the dagger into Louis
是的，深挖潜能。是的。所以对可怜的达米安来说，这确实是糟糕的一天。他被放进了一辆运囚车。他被发给了一支燃烧的蜡烛让他们拿着，然后被带到通常举行处决的广场，也就是市政厅旁边的格雷夫广场（Place de Grève）。他用匕首刺入路易
the 15th is burned using sulphur, so connotations of hell. The executioners then take red hot pincers and remove little gobbets of flesh from his body. And the office of the watch, who was supervising later recorded that what the executioner took away formed at each part, a wound about the size of a six pound crown piece. We know that executioners love spoons. They have another spoon at this point. Yeah. I hope it's a different spoon. It is a different, because, because what he's dipping it into is a mixture of molten lead boiling oil, burning resin, wax and sulfur melted together. And he then kind of pours this into the various wounds that have been created.
十五的那只手被硫磺灼烧，带有地狱的内涵。然后刽子手拿出烧红的钳子，从他身上一块块地撕下肉。监督此事的治安官后来记录道，刽子手每次取下的部分，都形成了一个大约相当于一枚六磅克朗硬币大小的伤口。我们知道刽子手喜欢勺子。他们此时又拿出了另一个勺子。是的。我希望那是另一个不同的勺子。它确实是一个不同的，因为他蘸进去的是一种由熔化的铅、沸油、燃烧的树脂、蜡和硫磺混合在一起的液体。然后他把这个浇在刚刚造成的各种伤口上。
As the flesh is being pulled off, as this liquid is being poured into the wounds, poor Damien is crying out as the damned in hell are supposed to cry out, pardon my God, pardon Lord. So he's still alive. He's then publicly emasculated. So his testicles and penis are chopped off, held up to the gawping crowd. And then comes the pièce de la résistance. Four horses are led into the square. Each of his four limbs are attached to a horse. The horses are whipped to make them move off. But unfortunately, this hasn't been done for about a hundred years. So the executions are up to speed with what you need to do. Nothing happens. He's not torn to pieces. So they stop the horses.
当血肉被撕裂，当这种液体被倒进伤口时，可怜的达米安像地狱里的罪人一样尖叫着喊道：饶恕我，我的上帝，饶恕我，主啊。所以他还活着。随后他被公开阉割。因此他的睾丸和阴茎被切掉，高举给目瞪口呆的群众看。然后是重头戏（pièce de la résistance）。四匹马被牵进广场。他的四肢分别绑在四匹马上。人们鞭打马匹让它们走开。但不幸的是，这种刑罚已经有一百年左右没有执行过了。所以刽子手们对需要做的事情并不熟练。什么都没发生。他没有被五马分尸。所以他们停下马。
They then cut his tendons and the horses are then whipped forwards. And at this point, the limbs go, and all you have left is his trunk. His limbs are burnt in front of him. He's still alive at this point. And then surely not conscious. What remains of him is burnt at the stake. I mean, this is probably the worst thing we've ever heard about on the rest of this history. This is unbelievable. So basically the lads have done good. They've set up the spectacle that people were hoping for.
接着他们割断了他的筋腱，然后再次鞭打马匹向前冲。在这个节点，四肢断裂，你剩下的只有他的躯干。他的四肢在他面前被烧毁。此时他仍然活着。然后肯定已经失去意识了。剩下的一切都被绑在火刑柱上烧毁。我的意思是，这可能是我们在《历史的余烬》中听过的最糟糕的事情了。这太难以置信了。所以基本上小伙子们干得不错。他们布置了人们一直期盼的奇观。
That's what the public wanted. That's what the public wanted. However, it's actually so horrific that it backfires. Executions do continue to be as popular as they've ever been after this particular spectacular. But I think that it leaves a sense among opinion formers, which has already been developing even before it, that it is actually unfashionable to gawp at them. And this in part, no doubt reflects the kind of the growing impact of the enlightenment Voltaire, you know, as we've said, was a vehement campaigner against these forms of punishment.
这正是公众想要的。这正是公众想要的。然而，它实际上是如此可怕，以至于适得其反。在此类壮观的处决之后，死刑确实一如既往地受欢迎。但我认为这给评论界人士留下了一种感觉——这种感觉甚至在此之前就已经开始发展——即去围观处决其实是一件很不体面的事。这无疑在某种程度上反映了启蒙运动对伏尔泰日益增长的影响力，正如我们所说，伏尔泰一直是反对这些惩罚形式的狂热活动家。
But remember it is the king himself. So Louis the 15th, who had been the object of Damien's assassination attempt, who actually gives the posthumous pardon to Cala. So it's not as though there's a complete kind of divergence between enlightenment thinkers and upholders of the Ancien Regime. Rousseau with his cult of sensibility is also, I think, a big influence in changing attitudes to these kind of public executions. But again, remember Marie Antoinette, great enthusiast for it. And I think also there is a kind of slightly misogynistic tinge to it because we mentioned how people focus on the women who are watching these executions. And there's one notorious woman who watches
但请记住，正是国王本人——也就是作为达米安暗杀目标的路线十五世——实际上给予了卡拉死后赦免。所以这并不是说启蒙思想家与旧制度的捍卫者之间存在完全的分歧。卢梭及其感性崇拜，我认为也是改变对这种公开处决态度的重要影响因素。但再次提醒，记住玛丽·安托瓦内特，她对此非常狂热。而且我认为这也带有一种略带厌女色彩的意味，因为我们提到人们如何关注那些观看这些处决的女性。有一个臭名昭зу的女性观看了
it, Madame Preonde, and she's described by a disapproving intellectual as one of the prettiest and one of the most stupid creatures that God created. And she had been watching the horses pull poor Damien to pieces and cried out, oh Jesus, the poor horses, how I pity them. Oh, the poor horses. Oh my word. It becomes kind of representative of the frivolity and cruelty and unthinking lack of...
它，普兰德夫人（Madame Preonde），她被一个不赞成的知识分子描述为上帝创造的“最漂亮也最愚蠢的生物”之一。当时她正看着马匹把可怜的达米安撕成碎片，并大声喊道：“哦，天哪，可怜的马，我多心疼它们啊。”“哦，可怜的马。”我的天哪。这变得有点代表了轻浮、残酷和缺乏思考……
The heedless sadism almost. And on Let Them Eat Cake, so Marion Twinnett herself, she never went to an execution. So she didn't enjoy the spectacle. No. Interesting. No. I mean, the point of that is that I don't think there's anything inherently revolutionary about kind of revulsion against the penal system. So potential for its reform is incubating within the Ancien Regime. Within those enlightenment monarchies of 18th century Europe, so Joseph the Second or Leopold the Second in Austria, for example,
近乎轻率的虐待狂。而在“让他们吃蛋糕吧”这一点上——玛丽·安托瓦内特本人，她从未去过刑场。所以她并不喜欢这种奇观。没有。有趣的是。我的意思是，这其中的重点在于，我对刑罚制度的厌恶本身并没有什么天然的革命性。因此，对其进行改革的潜力正在18世纪欧洲的旧制度内部孕育，比如奥地利的约瑟夫二世或利奥波德二世，
they had been reformers. They had been trying to clean up what they saw as these antiquated relics of a barbaric dark age. Yeah, but having said that, it is striking how the memory of executions like Damien's execution and of people broken on the wheel and all that, it does play a huge part in the image of the Ancien Régime that comes to be enshrined by the revolution. And actually, which endures to this day, it is seen as representative of everything that the revolution is fighting against. And it is striking how many of the future leaders of the revolution are in the decades before the revolution breaks out kind of swept up on a kind of wave of opposition to the death penalty. So Robespierre in 1785, he had written an article in which he proposed that the death penalty, if it
他们一直是改革者。他们一直试图清理他们视为野蛮黑暗时代陈旧遗迹的东西。是的，但话虽如此，令人瞩目的是，像达米安处决以及受车裂之刑等处决的记忆，确实在革命所奉行的旧制度形象中扮演了极其重要的角色。事实上，这种形象一直延续到今天，它被视为革命所反对的一切事物的代表。令人瞩目的是，在革命爆发前的几十年里，许多未来的革命领袖都卷入了反对死刑的浪潮之中。所以罗伯斯庇尔在1785年曾写过一篇文章，在文中他提议死刑如果
absolutely has to be imposed, should be swift, should be merciful. And he, you know, there's a class element to this. So he wrote, whereas the gallows stigmatize the relatives of a commoner forever, the iron which fells the head of a great man imprints no stain on his posterity. His actual preference, ironically, is for the death penalty to be abolished altogether. Yeah, I love that irony. I mean, he's very keen on that. As is Briceau, who we talked about in our previous episode. And we talked about how he was kind of an activist, a humanitarian activist. And in
绝对必须实施，应当迅速，应当仁慈。而且他，你知道，这里面有一个阶级因素。所以他写道，绞架永远耻辱一个平民的亲属，而砍下一个伟人头颅的铁器却不会给他的后代留下任何污点。讽刺的是，他真正的倾向其实是彻底废除死刑。是的，我喜欢这种讽刺。我的意思是，他非常热衷于这一点。正如布里索一样，我们在上一集里谈到过他。我们谈到他如何是一种积极分子，一个人道主义积极分子。而在
1780, he won a prize for an essay in which he compared the death penalty in France to the atrocity of cannibals. And he argued that criminals, instead of being executed, should be put into penal servitude and that this would kill two birds with one stone because on the one hand it would be humane, there'd be no shedding of blood by the state. And on the other hand, it would enable the black slaves in the Caribbean colonies to be set free and to be replaced by criminals. So he wrote, replace those unhappy Negroes who are guilty only of having a languid look and of absorbing the rays of light in the epidermis. Replace those Negroes in your plantations, your sugar factories and your mills with the condemned whom you judge deserving of being
1780年，他因一篇论文获奖，在文中他将法国的死刑比作食人族的暴行。他认为罪犯不应该被处决，而应该被判处苦役，这将一石二鸟，因为一方面这很有人情味，国家不会流血。另一方面，它将使加勒比殖民地的黑奴获得自由，并由罪犯取而代之。因此他写道，用那些只因面容忧郁、吸收表皮光线的罪有应得的不幸黑人来替代吧。用死刑犯取代你们种植园、糖厂和磨坊里的那些黑人，你们认为他们剥夺了对人类有害的自由是罪有应得的。
deprived of a liberty, which is dangerous to the human race. And so for all these reasons, it's unsurprising I think that when the revolution breaks out, the reform of the death penalty, whether to abolish it completely or whether to introduce new strictures, new articles that would govern how it's applied comes to be very high on the agenda. Enter Madame Guillotine. All right, Tom, let's take a break. And when we return, we will have our appointment with a formidable madame. I'm Marina Hyde.
因此，由于所有这些原因，我认为毫不奇怪，当革命爆发时，死刑的改革——无论是彻底废除它，还是引入新的限制、管理其应用的新条款——在议程上变得非常高。有请吉约坦夫人。好吧，汤姆，我们休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将与一位令人生畏的夫人有约。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐其余》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告的节目、奖励剧集并提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
That's the rest is entertainment.com. Painting a portrait, which was as picturesque as it was sensitive, of the terrifying punishments which have endured even in the century of humanity – gibbets, wheels, scaffolds, burnings at the stake, barbarous punishments invented by barbarous feudalism – he concluded by proposing the following article. In all cases in which the law pronounced the death penalty against the accused, the punishment will be the same, no matter the nature of the crime for which he has been found guilty. Decapitation and the execution will take place by the effect of a simple mechanism.
那是therestisentertainment.com。他描绘了一幅既生动又敏感的肖像，描绘了即使在人道主义世纪也依然存在的可怕惩罚——绞刑架、车裂、断头台、火刑柱、野蛮的封建制度发明的野蛮惩罚——他最后提出了以下条款。在法律对被告判处死刑的所有情况下，无论其被判有罪的犯罪性质如何，惩罚都将是相同的。斩首，并且通过一个简单的机制来执行。
Monsieur Guillotin gave a description of the mechanism. The mechanism falls like thunder. The head flies off. The blood spurts. The man is no more. So that was a report in the Journal des Étaires Généraux, the newspaper of the Estates General, on a speech that was given by Dr. Joseph Ignace Guillotin to the National Assembly in November 1789. So the revolution
吉约坦先生对这个机制进行了描述。这个机制像雷鸣一样落下。头颅飞走。鲜血四溅。人就不复存在了。因此，这是《三级会议报》（Journal des États Généraux）上关于约瑟夫·伊纳斯·吉约坦（Joseph Ignace Guillotin）医生于1789年11月向国民议会发表的演讲的报道。所以革命
is less than six months old. And there's Dr. Guillotin explaining how this humane, progressive, merciful, egalitarian form of capital punishment will lead France into a brave new dawn. So Tom, take it away. So just to say the sources for all this are really amazing. I mean, you can trace the way that the argument on all of this evolves over the course of the early months and years of the revolution. And I mean, anyone interested, Paul Friedland's translated them in his book. So this is where I've got the translations from. They're really, really interesting to follow. So anyway, back to Dr. Guertin. We've actually already met him in this series because listeners may remember
还不到六个月。吉约坦医生正在解释这种人道、进步、仁慈、平等的死刑形式将如何引领法国走向一个崭新的黎明。所以，汤姆，你来吧。顺便说一句，这一切的资料真的太惊人了。我的意思是，你可以追踪关于这一切的争论在革命的早期几个月和几年里是如何演变的。我的意思是，任何感兴趣的人，保罗·弗里德兰（Paul Friedland）在他的书里翻译了这些。这就是我获得这些翻译的地方。追踪起来真的非常非常有趣。言归正传，回到吉约坦医生。其实我们在这系列节目中已经见过他了，因为听众可能还记得
that when the members of the third estate had found themselves locked out of their meeting hall in June 1789, and they didn't have anywhere to go, Dr. Guillotin stands up and proposes that they meet in the tennis court, which they then proceed to do. So he's exactly the kind of man who gets elected to the third estate in the elections to that crucial and decisive assembly of the estates general. He's actually a gérant d'un, he's born north of Bordeaux in 1738. And according to family tradition, which I really like to believe actually happened, he was born prematurely because his mother had been startled by the screams of a man being broken on the wheel. That undoubtedly happened. Yeah, I like to think so. So he was a very clever boy.
当第三等级的成员发现自己在1789年6月被锁在会议大厅外面，无处可去时，吉约坦医生站起来提议他们在网球场开会，他们随后也这样做了。所以他正是那种在三级会议那个至关重要且具有决定性意义的选举中当选第三等级代表的人。他实际上是波尔多以北出生的，1738年出生。根据家族传统——我其实很愿意相信这是真的，他之所以早产，是因为他的母亲被一个受刑者的惨叫声吓到了。那绝对是发生了。是的，我也愿意这么想。所以他是一个非常聪明的男孩。
He was brought up by the Jesuits, actually trained as a Jesuit, then left the order when he was 25, became a doctor and he was a very passionate social reformer. So he was a great man for being co-opted onto Quangos, that kind of thing, doing investigations into social injustices. So he wrote a whole report for the government on the draining of swamps. Fascinating. He was also rather sinisterly, but I'm sure he did it from the most humanitarian principles. He was against doing rabies experiments on animals and thought that it should be done on criminals.
他由耶稣会士抚养长大，实际上受过耶稣会士的训练，然后在25岁时离开修会，成为了一名医生，他是一位非常热情的社会改革家。所以他非常热衷于被吸纳进各种准政府机构（Quangos）之类的地方，对社会不公正现象进行调查。因此，他为政府撰写了关于排干沼泽的整份报告。太迷人了。他也相当阴险，但我确信他是出于最人道主义的原则。他反对在动物身上做狂犬病实验，认为应该在罪犯身上做。
But he justified this by saying it was very progressive. So he wrote, a biting sensation, the painful symptoms of illness are these to be compared with the appalling torments undergone by a man whose bones are being broken, who is forced to expire in the anguish of despair? Do you rather be Britain by a rabid rat or would you rather be broken on the wheel? I think I would rather be bitten by a rabid rat. Yeah, I would too, I think. I'd take that over the wheel, definitely. Yeah, I think I would. So I think, I think Giertan is, I mean, I think he's got the ball there. Yeah, hats off to him.
但他为自己辩护说这非常进步。所以他写道，一种刺痛感，痛苦的疾病症状，这些能与一个骨头被打碎、被迫在绝望的痛苦中气绝身亡的人所遭受的可怕折磨相提并论吗？你宁愿被一只疯老鼠咬，还是宁愿被车裂？我想我宁愿被一只疯老鼠咬。是的，我想我也是。我肯定会选择那个而不是车裂。是的，我想我会的。所以我想，我认为吉约坦，我的意思是，我认为他抓住了要害。是的，向他致敬。
Sensible policies for a happier France. And so you can imagine this being the kind of man he is, he loves the early days of the revolution. Because there are committees being set up left, right and centre. Brilliant. I can write loads of reports, spend all my time on committees and have people bitten by rabid rats. Love it. He's obviously a genuinely very compassionate man who really works hard to try and improve the condition of those who are suffering, those who are poor, those who are disadvantaged. So he's elected a member of the poverty committee. And then Marky Desaard, remember, was co-opted onto a committee investigating orphanages. And maybe not entirely the best person to
为了一个更幸福的法国的明智政策。所以你可以想象，以他这样的人格，他热爱革命的早期。因为到处都在成立委员会。太棒了。我可以写大量的报告，把所有时间都花在委员会上，让人们被疯老鼠咬。太棒了。他显然是一个真正非常有同情心的人，他真的很努力地试图改善那些受苦的人、那些穷人、那些处于不利地位的人的状况。所以他当选为贫困委员会的成员。然后萨德侯爵（Marquis de Sade），请记住，被吸纳进了一个调查孤儿院的委员会。也许并不是最适合承担这个责任的人。
be enrolled in that responsibility. But Giertan, I think, who also has a focus on foundlings and orphans, he's much better qualified for this kind of work. And he also writes a massive report on sickness provision for the poor. So he's very much in the cause of good, but the cause for which he becomes, well, not famous, notorious really, is penal reform. And personally, like Robespierre, he wants to abolish the death penalty, but he also knows that probably this is too much to hope for. It's too big an ask. And so his secondary ambition is to make it more humane, to make it more enlightened. And the thing is, as we intimated in the first half, he is kind
但吉约坦，我认为，他也关注弃儿和孤儿，他更适合这种工作。他还撰写了一份关于穷人医疗保障的大型报告。所以他非常投身于善良的事业，但他真正变得——与其说是著名，不如说是声名狼藉——的事业是刑罚改革。就个人而言，就像罗伯斯庇尔一样，他想废除死刑，但他也知道这可能奢求太多了。这是一个太大的要求。因此他的第二大野心是让它更有人情味，让它更开明。问题是，正如我们在前半部分所暗示的那样，他有点
of pushing it an open door with this. It's not as though there is an institutional opposition to this on the part, say, of the monarchy. So Louis XVI has been introducing laws here, laws there, to kind of make it less likely that people will be sentenced to death. So 1775, for instance, he'd abolished death penalty for desertion, unless there was an actual war being fought at the time. 1788, so the year before the revolution breaks out, he had increased the number of judges that were required to deliver a death sentence. So in other words, to make it harder. So he's working with that, but he's also working with the
在这方面推开了一扇开着的门。并不是说君主制方面对此有什么制度上的反对。路易十六一直在颁布这样那样的法律，以降低人们被判死刑的可能性。例如，1775年，他废除了逃兵的死刑，除非当时正在进行实际的战争。1788年，也就是革命爆发前一年，他增加了做出死刑判决所需的法官人数。换句话说，是为了让死刑更难判决。所以他一直在利用这一点，但他也利用了
natural instinct of the revolutionaries to get rid of anything that smacks of feudalism and smacks of superstition. And obviously having an executioner in a blood red robe, kind of pulling bits of flesh out with red hot pincers. This is exactly the kind of thing that a revolutionary instinctively is going to be opposed to. Yeah, of course. And so this is why he feels when he stands up in the National Assembly on the 8th of October 1789, he feels that, you know, he's going to get a good audience. The problem is that this is immediately after the removal of the King and Queen from Versailles by the women who've come out from Paris. And the delegates are still in Versailles, but they're understandably a little
革命者摆脱任何带有封建气息和迷信气息的东西的天然本能。显然，有一个穿着血红色长袍的行刑者，用红热的钳子拔出肉块。这正是革命者本能会反对的东西。是的，当然。这就是为什么当他在1789年10月8日站在国民议会上时，他觉得自己会得到一个很好的听众。问题是，这紧随巴黎妇女从凡尔赛将国王和王后带走之后。代表们仍然在凡尔赛，但他们可以理解地有点震惊，有点不安。
bit shell shocked, a little bit kind of unsettled. And so Girtan's proposals don't really get the attention that they may be deserved. But there are, you know, there are a few people who turn up to listen to him and his proposals, the first of which is in his words, crimes of the same kind shall be punished by the same kinds of punishment, whatever the rank or estate of the criminal. So in other words, rather than having people broken on the wheel or being pulled apart by horses or whatever, you just have the one system of execution for everybody, no matter their rank, no matter their status, no matter their gender. He proposes
所以吉约坦的提议并没有真正得到应有的关注。但确实有一些人出现来听他的演讲和他的提议，其中的第一条用他的话说就是：同类罪行应受到同种刑罚的惩罚，无论罪犯的阶级或身份如何。换句话说，与其让人受车裂之刑或五马分尸之刑等，不如对所有人实行单一的死刑执行系统，无论其阶级、身份、性别如何。他提议
furthermore that the form of execution should be beheading because it is the most humane way of death. And he proposes that the decapitation be done by, and I quote, a simple mechanism. And these proposals are seen as being controversial. The delegates pass the first article, so the one that there should be only a single form of execution. They feel it's going too far to pass the other provisions, the other articles. And so a month and a half later, Guertin goes back to the attack. And this is a speech that was being reported in the newspaper, the newspaper that you quoted. Finally, on the 21st of January, 1790, all of his proposals are accepted except for the sixth and last one. And that's the one where Guiartin proposes the introduction of a simple mechanism for beheading the condemned.
此外，死刑的执行形式应该是斩首，因为这是最人道的人死方式。他提议砍头应该通过，我引用的话，“一个简单的机制”来完成。这些提议被视为具有争议性。代表们通过了第一条，也就是只有一种单一的死刑执行形式。他们觉得通过其他规定、其他条款走得太远了。因此，在一个半月后，吉约坦再次发起进攻。这就是报纸上报道的演讲，也就是你引用的那份报纸。最终，在1790年1月21日，他所有的提议都被接受了，除了第六条也是最后一条。那是吉约坦提议引入一种简单机制来对死刑犯进行斩首的条款。
And this is reported widely and it makes guillotine an object of public ridicule. People just find this, the whole idea of this hilarious. The idea of a machine they find inherently ridiculous. I mean, the thing is, it's not a novelty. These machines have been developed and invented. So there was actually, there was one in England, but it's seen as being ludicrous, a bit like the, the scientists in Gulliver's Travels who, you know, are trying to extract some beans from cucumbers. Yeah. Yeah. It's seen as being ludicrous, a bit like the scientist in Gulliver's Travels who, you know, are trying to extract some beans from cucumbers.
这得到了广泛报道，并使吉约坦成为公众嘲笑的对象。人们觉得这个想法，整个概念极其滑稽。机器的想法在他们看来本质上就是荒谬的。我的意思是，这不是什么新鲜事。这些机器已经被开发和发明出来了。实际上，英国就有一台，但它被认为是荒谬的，有点像《格列佛游记》里的科学家，你知道的，他们试图从黄瓜里提取豆子。是的。是的。它被认为是荒谬的，有点像《格列佛游记》里的科学家，你知道的，他们试图从黄瓜里提取豆子。
Yeah. It's kind of, it's seen as... And Boffin's mad scheme. Yes. And Guillotin particularly comes to seem the kind of the archetype of a do-gooding utopianist whose schemes simply outrun what is sensible. And so a song is written about him in which his machine is called the guillotine, the guillotine. Right.
是的。这有点像……还有博芬（Boffin）疯狂的计划。是的。吉约坦尤其开始看起来像是那种行善的空想家的原型，他们的计划完全超出了理智的范围。因此，一首关于他的歌被创作出来，歌中他的机器被称为吉约坦机（guillotine，断头台）。对。
And it becomes very, very popular. You know, like songs are spreading across the streets of Paris. This song about the guillotine, you know, people love it. So the guillotine, the word, it begins as a joke of the guillotine and guillotine's expense. It does. It's part of a comic song. But the truth is that guillotine is, you know, he's ahead of the curve because as events will show, his proposal for a beheading machine
它变得非常非常受欢迎。你知道的，就像歌曲在巴黎街头传唱一样。这首关于断头台的歌，人们很喜欢。所以，断头台这个词，最初是作为对吉约坦及其开销的一个笑话开始的。确实如此。它是喜剧歌曲的一部分。但事实是，吉约坦，你知道的，他走在了时代的前面，因为正如事实将证明的那样，他关于斩首机器的提议
that will be swift and humane is brilliant for enabling the two seemingly opposed trends that we've been discussing in this episode to meet and to fuse. So on the one hand, this relish for kind of, you know, a spectacular and salutary display of justice that will be thrilling to people. The people can feel it simultaneously moral and exciting. And secondly, the notion that executions should be humane and should repudiate feudalism, should repudiate superstition. So it's both improving, well, it's improving in every sense. It's improving as it works as a spectacular deterrent to crime,
迅速而人道，非常适合将我们本集一直在讨论的两个看似对立的趋势结合并融合在一起。一方面，这种对一种戏剧性和有益的、会让人们感到刺激的公正展示的热衷。人们可以同时感受到它既有道德又令人兴奋。其次，这种观念认为，处决应该有人情味，应该唾弃封建主义，应该唾弃迷信。所以它既在改善——嗯，它在各个意义上都在改善。它作为对犯罪的壮观威慑在发挥作用，
but it's improving in that it also, it's more humane, it's clean, it's progressive, it's modern. So what's not to like? Right, and so an obvious way in which you can make the penal system modern is to get rid of all the shenanigans around executions, having their tin-plated spoons and their blood red robes and all this kind of thing. And to do that requires the delegates in the National Assembly essentially to rule that the executioner is just a state functionary.
但它也在改善，因为它更有人道，干净，进步，现代。所以有什么不喜欢它的地方呢？对，因此使 penal 系统现代化的一个显着方法是摆脱关于处决的所有胡闹，比如锡制勺子、血红长袍之类的事情。要做到这一点，基本上需要国民议会的代表们裁定行刑者只是一个国家官员。
He's nothing special. So he's part of a group of people that include Jews and include actors who had suffered kind of civic disabilities under the Ancien Regime and now they're to be enrolled simply as everyday citizens. Right. But even in the final legislation that passes this, they still can't bring themselves to specify executioners. There's still a kind of superstitious sense in which even to mention the name is cursed. But the legislation gets passed and so the civic status of Saint-Saëns and other executioners
他没什么特别的。所以他是犹太人和演员等一群人在旧制度下遭受过公民残疾的人的一部分，现在他们将被简单地登记为日常公民。对。但即使在通过这项最终立法时，他们仍然无法让自己明确指出行刑者。仍然有一种迷信的感觉，甚至提到这个名字都是受诅咒的。但立法通过了，因此桑松（Sanson）和其他行刑者的公民身份
is normalized. And this is significant because it transforms the figure of the executioner into a servant of the revolution, into someone who is simply doing a civic duty. Nothing wrong with that. Perfectly rational, perfectly enlightened, perfectly progressive. But having said all that, there are still limits on how far the National Assembly are prepared to go in being progressive. Right.
正常化了。这意义重大，因为它将行刑者的形象转变为革命的公仆，转变为一个只是在履行公民职责的人。这没什么不对。完全理性，完全开明，完全进步。话虽如此，国民议会在走向进步的道路上仍然有其局限性。对。
So they're not going to scrap it completely. I mean, that's the pale, right? So at the end of May 1791, there is a debate on precisely this, and there is a vote on whether the death penalty should be completely abolished. Robespierre argues that it should, votes in favour of its abolition. But the majority of delegates disagree. And so the death penalty is maintained. There is an even more radical proposal than simply abolishing the death penalty. I mean, this kind of strikes at the heart of so many assumptions that people are utterly shocked by it, which is that executions, if they are to be maintained and it's decided
所以他们不打算彻底废除它。我的意思是，那是底线，对吧？所以在1791年5月底，正好就此进行了一场辩论，并就死刑是否应该彻底废除进行了投票。罗伯斯庇尔认为应该废除，并投了赞成票。但大多数代表不同意。因此死刑得以保留。甚至还有一个比单纯废除死刑更激进的提案。我的意思是，这触及了许多假设的核心，以至于人们感到无比震惊，那就是处决，如果它们要被保留——并且已经决定
that they will be, should be done privately. In other words, the salutary quality of it, the way in which executions serve to educate our people, that should be removed. The removal of a criminal should be like kind of the excision of a cancerous tumor or something. It should just be done neatly, cleanly and privately. People can't get their heads around this idea at all. It's kind of howled down. And so it's agreed that public executions will be maintained and they will be public. But then there is the problem of how, how should these executions take
它们将被保留——应该私下进行。换句话说，它的有益品质，处决用来教育我们人民的方式，应该被移除。移除一个罪犯应该就像切除一个癌性肿瘤之类的东西。它应该干脆利落地私下完成。人们根本无法理解这个想法。它遭到了一片嘘声。因此，人们同意公开处决将得以保留，并且它们将是公开的。但随后出现了问题，如何进行这些处决？
place? It's been agreed that there will be only the one method. So that one method needs to be decided upon. And essentially there are two alternatives. There's hanging, which is traditionally the way for the poor, as in Britain, or to be beheaded, which traditionally has been the way for the aristocracy. And because nothing is too good for the people, it's taken for granted that actually hanging is unacceptable, that everyone should now enjoy the rights that traditionally had been the rights of the aristocracy, partly because of that,
人们已经同意只有一种方法。所以需要确定那一种方法。基本上有两种选择。一种是绞刑，这传统上是穷人的方式，就像在英国一样，或者是斩首，这传统上是贵族的方式。因为没有什么对人民来说是过于美好的，所以人们理所当然地认为绞刑是不可接受的，现在每个人都应该享有传统上属于贵族的权利，部分原因在于此，
but also because it is seen as being quicker, it's more humane. But the person who raises objections to this, because if everyone is going to be beheaded, that would potentially require large numbers of people to be dispatched by losing their heads in one go. The person who objects to this is Saint-Saens, who is no longer the royal executioner, but he's still the chief executioner now the revolution. He presents various arguments against doing
但也因为它被认为更快，更有人道。但是对此提出反对意见的人——因为如果每个人都要被斩首，这可能会要求大量的人通过一次性失去脑袋来被处决——提出反对意见的人是桑松，他不再是皇家行刑者，但他仍然是革命后的首席行刑者。他提出了各种反对这样做的理由。一个是这需要高超的技巧，当然桑松会这么争辩，但我的意思是，他并没有错。
it. One is that it requires great skill, which of course Saint-Saens would argue that, but I mean, he's not wrong. Right. Cause we've covered executions on this podcast. I think about the Duke of Monmouth and Jack Ketch, who had to take eight strokes of the ax or whatever before he managed to get his head off. That's a standard, isn't it? There's always these disastrous scenes on the block where they make a mess of it and it's really bloody and horrible.
因为我们在这个播客中讨论过处决。我想到了蒙茅斯公爵（Duke of Monmouth）和杰克·凯奇（Jack Ketch），他不得不挥斧八次左右才成功把头砍下来。这是一个标准，不是吗？行刑木桩上总是出现这些灾难性的场景，他们把事情搞砸了，非常血腥可怕。
Yeah. And Sanson was saying that the only way that you could possibly do this is to train up other people, but they, you know, it takes a long time to do it also, there's the risk that if you're using the same acts, the blade will become dull, but above all, he says, you know, it is very, very bloody. So if you remember how guillotine presented his arguments in favor of it, he's very in suciant about it. He's saying, you know, the blood spurts, the man is no more brilliant. Yeah. But that's what I'm saying. Actually, you know, this is going to be horrific. Blood just
是的。而桑松说，你唯一可能做到的方法就是训练其他人，但这，你知道的，需要很长时间才能做到，另外，如果你使用同一把斧头，刀刃会变钝，但最重要的是，他说，这非常非常血腥。所以如果你还记得吉约坦是如何提出支持它的论点的，他对此非常漫不经心。他说，你知道，血四溅，人就不复存在了，太棒了。是的。但这就是我所说的。实际上，你知道的，这会是可怕的。到处都是血
going everywhere. We can't do that. We need a much more efficient way of sorting this out. So I'll quote you this memorandum that he writes to the National Assembly. When there shall be several condemned criminals who will be executed at the same time, the terror created by this form of execution because of the immensity of blood, which it produces and which it spreads out will give rise to fright and weakness in even the most intrepid of those who remain to be executed. So in other words, you've got people lining up and there's blood everywhere. So the people at the back of the queue will completely lose it and will not be executed in a decorous way because they'll be shouting and gibbering
到处流。我们不能那样做。我们需要一个更有效的方法来解决这个问题。所以我引用他写给国民议会的一份备忘录。当有数名罪犯同时被处决时，由于这种行刑方式产生并散播的大量血液，这种行刑方式所造成的恐怖将在那些等待被处决的人中最无畏的人中间引起恐惧和虚脱。换句话说，人们排着队，到处都是血。所以队伍后面的那些人会彻底崩溃，无法以得体的方式被处决，因为他们会大喊大叫、胡言乱语
and behaving badly. Yeah. And this won't be teaching an elevated lesson to the people. It'll be a shambles, Tom. It'll be rubbish. Yeah. So the delegates take all this on board and they think actually, you know, Dr. Geertas proposal, it's not completely mad. So they go to a surgeon, Dr. Antoine Louis, who is the permanent secretary to the Academy of Surgery, and they say, could you kind of work out what the best kind of machine would be? So Louis goes away and he analyzes what angle the blade should be at, what would be
并且表现糟糕。是的。这不会给人民上一堂高尚的课。这会是一团糟，汤姆。这会是垃圾。是的。所以代表们将这一切记在心里，他们认为实际上，你知道的，吉约坦医生的提议并非完全疯狂。所以他们去找一位外科医生——安托万·路易（Antoine Louis）医生，他是外科科学院的常务秘书，他们说，你能弄清楚什么样的机器才是最好的吗？所以路易去分析了刀刃应该处于什么角度，刀刃落下的最有效角度是什么。
the most efficient angle for the blade to come down. He kind of inspects the vertebrae, works out what's the best way to cut through them. And he draws up his report and he hands it back to the National Assembly. And Louis's conclusion is, for the certainty of the procedure and to ensure that decapitation will take place in an instant in accord with the spirit and the will of the new law, there is no option but to rely on invariable mechanical methods. So in other words, remove human error, get a machine. And so the delegates of the National Assembly go to Dr. Guillotin and say, you know, do you want to take control of this?
他检查了脊椎，找出了切断它们的最佳方式。他起草了报告并交回给国民议会。路易的结论是：为了确保程序的确定性，并确保斩首能够在瞬间发生，以符合新法律的精神和意志，别无选择，只能依靠一成不变的机械方法。换句话说，消除人为错误，弄一台机器来。因此，国民议会的代表们去找吉约坦医生，说，你知道的，你想掌控这个吗？
You know, he's so offended by this. He doesn't have anything to do with it. Really? He turns them down. Because he's been made fun of in the song and stuff. Yeah. So he's very disgruntled by this. He's in a huge sulk.
你知道，他对此感到非常被冒犯。他根本不想跟这有任何关系。真的吗？他拒绝了他们。因为他在歌曲和其他东西中被取笑了。是的。所以他对这件事非常不满。他在生一场大闷气。
He's in a strop. Yeah. So Dr. Louie, he keeps control of the project and he turns to this guy called Tobias Schmidt who is a German as his name implies. He's a piano maker. He's also an alcoholic which you might think is slightly worrying for a man who's going to invent a decapitation machine but actually he does a tremendous job. It's already one month later. And Louis then does tests. So first of all, he does it on a sheep, then he does it on a calf. And then finally he gets three human corpses and the head's sliced off. And Louis is absolutely delighted. So to quote him, one is astonished by the force and celerity of its action. And it is now April 1792. And so the time is ready to try out
他在闹脾气。是的。所以路易医生保留了对这个项目的控制权，他找到了一个名叫托比亚斯·施密特（Tobias Schmidt）的人，正如他的名字所暗示的那样，他是一个德国人。他是一个钢琴制造商。他也是个酒鬼，你可能会认为这对于一个将要发明斩首机器的人来说有点令人担忧，但实际上他做得非常出色。仅仅一个月后。然后路易进行了测试。首先，他在一只羊身上测试，然后在小牛身上测试。最后他弄了三具人类尸体，把头切了下来。路易绝对高兴极了。引述他的话，
the execution machine on the first victim. And the first victim is a highwayman called Nicolas-Jacques Pelletier, who had committed armed robbery in October 1791. Had been sentenced to death in December. Has been in prison awaiting his execution. And he is the person who on the 25th of April, 1792, is led out to the Place de la Greve, the traditional place of execution, where there is standing a peculiar looking machine. And the news has got out.
人们为其行动的力量和迅捷感到惊讶。现在是1792年4月。因此，时机已经成熟，可以在第一个受害者身上试用这台行刑机器。第一个受害者是一个名叫尼古拉-雅克·佩勒蒂埃（Nicolas-Jacques Pelletier）的江洋大盗，他在1791年10月犯下了持械抢劫罪。12月被判处死刑。一直在监狱里等待处决。他就是那个在1792年4月25日被带到格雷夫广场（Place de la Grève，传统行刑地点）的人，那里立着一台看起来很奇特的机器。消息已经传出去了。
So there's a large crowd to witness it. Paletier is led up to the scaffold by Saint-Saëns. Saint-Saëns cuts off his hair, ties Paletier's hands behind his back, straps him down onto a board, pushes him out so that his neck is exposed to the blade, pulls on a rope, the blade slices down, the head vanishes into a sack and that's it. It's all over. And the crowd are completely bewildered. Yeah, gutting for the crowd who've been queuing there probably for hours and it's done and
所以有大批人群来见证它。佩勒蒂埃被桑松带上绞架。桑松剪掉他的头发，把佩勒蒂埃的双手反绑在背后，将他绑在木板上，把他推出去，使他的脖子暴露在刀刃下，拉动绳子，刀刃飞速切下，头颅消失在一个麻袋里，就这样。一切都结束了。人群完全困惑了。是的，对于可能在那里排了几个小时队的人群来说，这太让人扫兴了，几秒钟就
dusted in seconds. Yeah. So a witness, very disgruntled eyewitness wrote, from the first point of contact to the last, there is no distance. It is an indivisible point. The blade falls and the patient no longer exists. The patient. Isn't that so interesting? The kind of medical metaphor. Yes. Because it is like a surgical operation. Yes. And when Giertan first proposed this machine, he commissioned illustrations,
搞定收工了。是的。所以一位非常不满的目击者写道，从接触的第一点到最后一点，没有距离。这是一个不可分割的点。刀刃落下，病人就不复存在了。病人。这不觉得很有趣吗？这种医疗隐喻。是的。因为这就像一次外科手术。是的。当吉约坦最初提出这台机器时，他委托制作了插图，
which show a priest ministering to the person who's about to have his head cut off, as though, you know, tending a deathbed or something like that. And this idea that it is, it's like having an operation. It's smooth, it's clear, it's kind of dignitas. And I think that the ambivalence is suggested by the name which the machine comes to be given, which of course is guillotine. So it's initially called a Louisette, but the association of Guillotin's name with this kind of contraption is too strong and so it ends up being named after him. And it's reflective of the way I think in which it comes to have its own mythology very, very rapidly. It's quick, it's efficient, it's humane, certainly relative to what had
图中有一个牧师在服侍那个即将被砍头的人，就好像，你知道的，在照顾临终床位之类的一样。这种观念认为它就像做手术一样。它流畅、清晰、有尊严。我认为这种矛盾心态体现在机器被赋予的名字上，当然就是吉约坦（guillotine）。它最初被称为路易斯ette（Louisette），但吉约坦的名字与这种玩意的联系太强烈了，所以它最终以他的名字命名。这反映了我认为它非常迅速地形成自己的神话的方式。它快速、高效、人道，当然相对于以前的情况而言，但它也非常非常血腥。
gone before, but it is also very, very bloody. And as Sanson had pointed out, the more criminals who are executed in one go, the more bloody the spectacle will become. And so, as we said, this fusion between the traditional spectacle and the new way of doing things, the guillotine kind of exemplifies it. But Tom, isn't it also that it's the fact that you can do so many people in one go. Yeah. And the uniformity of it is what is chilling. So the previous way of execution as unbelievably horrific as that was, there
正如桑松所指出的，一次性处决的罪犯越多，这场奇观就会变得越血腥。因此，正如我们所说，传统奇观与新做事方式之间的这种融合，断头台堪称典范。但汤姆，难道不是因为你可以一次性处决这么多人吗？是的。它的整齐划一令人不寒而栗。因此，以前的行刑方式虽然难以置信地可怕，但
was something about it that kind of respected you as an individual, you are Calas or Damien or whatever his name is, and you are brought out and this whole day is about you, you're at the center of it and it's specific to you. I mean, I'm not sure that's a great consolation. No, of course not. It's not a great consolation, but with this, isn't it that the, the ominous thing about it, especially looking back from the 21st century is that you can polish off dozens, hundreds of people in a day or two, and they're just numbers, people in a queue.
它某种程度上尊重了你的个人身份，你是卡拉斯（Calas）或达米安（Damiens）或随便叫什么名字，你被带出来，这一整天都围绕着你，你处于核心位置，这是针对你的。我的意思是，我不确定这算是什么巨大的安慰。不，当然不是。这算不上什么巨大的安慰，但有了这个，难道不是……特别从21世纪回看，它 ominous 的地方在于你可以在一天或两天内消灭几十人、数百人，而他们只是数字，队伍里的人。
Yeah, they're anonymous. They're anonymous. It's the anonymity of it that they think is the frightening thing, isn't it? Isn't that what? Yes. But it also, of course, forms its own spectacle. The spectacle of a large line of people being beheaded. Yeah.
是的，他们是匿名的。他们是匿名的。正是这种匿名性让人觉得可怕，不是吗？难道不是这样吗？是的。但当然，它也形成了它自己的奇观。一大排人被斩首的奇观。是的。
You know, it's extraordinary. No one's ever seen anything like it before. And so even though the theatrical quality of the executions, as you said, has been banned, there is a new theatricality about this and you get larger and larger crowds for it. And so the guillotine is moved from the Place de la Grève to ever larger venues. And it will end up being put in what today is the Place de la Concorde, but comes to be named the Place de la Révolution after the abolition of the monarchy. And there it comes to stand as the kind of the defining emblem of the revolution and people want to
你知道，这太不可思议了。以前谁也没见过这样的东西。因此，尽管正如你所说，行刑的戏剧性已经被禁止，但这有了一种新的戏剧性，你会为它吸引到越来越多的人群。因此，断头台从格雷夫广场搬到了更大的场地。它最终将矗立在今天的协和广场（Place de la Concorde），但在废除君主制后被命名为革命广场（Place de la Révolution）。在那里，它成为革命的标志性象征，人们想要
watch it. So it has become a spectacle kind of despite itself. And that's why it's so appropriate that Sasson, who had been the royal executioner, is now the executioner operating for the execution of the enemies of the revolution. And it's, it's why even though you no longer have, you know, female aristocrats gathering at private windows to go, you do have women in particular who become notorious for the delight they take in the spectacle of death. And these of course are the trickle tours, the women who knit. These are the women from the market who had gone and seize the king and queen from Versailles
观看它。所以它在某种程度上违背其本意成了一个奇观。这就是为什么曾担任皇家行刑者的桑松现在成为执行革命敌人死刑的行刑者是如此贴切。这就是为什么——尽管你不再有贵族女性聚集在私人窗户前观看——你确实有女性，特别是那些以从死亡奇观中获得的乐趣而臭名昭著的女性。这些当然就是织毛衣的妇女（tricoteuses）。这些是2000年1789年从凡尔赛抓走国王和王后的市场妇女，她们因此获得了特殊的特权。她们坐在前排。
in 1789 and who have particular privileges as a result. They get the front row. So the sense of rupture is obviously very, very profound, but so too beneath the seeming show there are continuities as well. And that I guess is one of the reasons why the guillotine is the kind of perfect symbol of the revolution really. Absolutely. Tom, that was absolutely fascinating. So the guillotine has been set up, the blade has been sharpened, the tumbles are rattling
因此，决裂感显然非常非常深刻，但在表象之下也存在着连续性。我想这就是断头台之所以成为革命的完美象征的原因之一。绝对是。汤姆，那真是太迷人了。所以断头台已经竖起，刀刃已经磨锋利，运囚车在街道上嘎嘎作响，
through the streets and there is going to be a steady stream of customers for Madame Guillotine because as we discussed last time, Tom, France is going to war. If you thought this episode was bloody, there is a lot more blood to come tomorrow. So you can listen to that episode right now if you're a member of the Restless History Club. If not, if you prefer the old fashioned ways of the wheel and the axe, then you'll just have to wait. Bye bye. Happy on too. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
将会有源源不断的吉约坦夫人顾客，因为正如我们上次讨论的那样，汤姆，法国正在开战。如果你觉得这一集很血腥，明天还会有更多的血。所以如果你是动荡历史俱乐部的会员，你现在就可以收听那一集。如果不是，如果你更喜欢车轮和斧头的旧传统，那你就只能等着了。拜拜。太棒了。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。